alors faut-il brandir la menace d'une
mise sous tutelle des allocations
familiales pour responsabiliser les
parents
c'est la question du 13 heures et cette
question de la posons à georges tron
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député maire de draveil dans
l'essonne
en fait c'est un peu votre idée qui a
été reprise dans ce projet de loi vous
avez vous même demandé la suppression
gens croient d'allocations communal
d'une quinzaine de familles parce que
les enfants des familles étaient
impliqués dans les violences urbaines la
suspension de ses allocations qui était
municipal qui était pas familiale en
gros l'idée d'être est simple elle
consiste à dire que nous mettons en
place suffisamment de dispositifs pour
aider les familles avant que le problème
ne se pose en termes de violence et donc
à partir du moment où tous les
dispositifs que nous mettons en place
n'aboutissent pas il faut que les
parents comprennent que on peut
sanctionner et cette sanction c'est la
suspension et non pas la suppression
alors justement est-ce que vous êtes sûr
que c'est vraiment la bonne arme à
utiliser que c'est au porte-monnaie
qu'il faut toucher ces familles qui sont
souvent on le sert déjà en très grande
difficulté financière
il nous faut le faire qu'en ultime
recours le texte d'ailleurs contient à
peu près 26 articles il ya deux articles
sur ce point précis et ces deux articles
précisent bien que ont abouti à la
suspension en mettant les allocations
sur un compte bloqué qui ensuite peut
être débloqués pour restituer les sommes
aux familles qu en ultime recours
ce qu'il faut c'est que les parents
comprennent que sans eux on ne peut rien
faire
pourquoi est ce que cette menace de
suspension d'allocations qu'elles soient
municipales ou familiale serait-elle
plus efficace justement que des mesures
d'accompagnement d'éducation de prise en
charge de ces familles elle est complète
toutes les mesures de prise en charge
des familles sont maintenant en place je
vais pas décrire devant vous faute de
temps tout ce que nous faisons dans les
communes
mais c'est très important il ya
plusieurs dispositifs pour cela mais
quand la famille et cela existe n'est
pas conscient de ses propres
responsabilités
quand les parents partent de l'idée
selon laquelle ce n'est plus leur
problème que de veiller par exemple à la
scolarisation des enfants
il faut qu'il comprenne qu'une sanction
qui peut tomber alors un dernier mot en
ce qui concerne le projet de loi cette
fois et parce qu'il se passe dans votre
commune
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque de voir
les travailleurs sociaux
contraint de devenir à la fois des
délateurs et peut-être même des
représentants de l'ordre
les travailleurs sociaux sont des relais
indispensable pour que ça fonctionne
bien dans les établissements il ya
quelques instants
le reportage précédent montre hic dans
un lycée il se passe plein de choses et
parfois graves
les travailleurs doivent informer leur
hiérarchie doivent informer
éventuellement le maire et c'est en
mettant tout le monde sur un pied
d'égalité dans les responsabilités les
parents les enseignants les élus avec
éventuellement une sanction qui peut
tomber quand on ne fait pas tout ce que
l'on doit faire chacun que l'on arrivera
je crois contrarier ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
merci d'être venu sur le plateau du 13
heures